why did you unfollow me why did you
unfollow me why did you unfollow me so
here's the thing Instagram is very
important in the 21st century and I've
spent the past year trying to figure it
out trying to grow my brand trying to
get followers so that people who take me
seriously and I can get opportunities in
life because without Instagram followers
you're nothing and I've been struggling
a little bit because in the past year
I've gained a lot of followers but I
have also lost an incredible amount of
followers I've definitely lost over like
30,000 followers in the past year that
means that over 30,000 people have
literally decided to never see me again
I remember one time I posted a picture
of my Jew fro and I lost 4,000 followers
after that picture 4,000 people they're
just scrolling on their Instagram they
don't care having a good day and then
they see my face and they go oh my god I
forgot about this kid why is he on my
Instagram let me take the time out of my
day to go on his page and unfollow him
because he sucks it's crazy to realize
that you're doing things that people
hate I don't know I don't know it's just
all what am i doing to piss these people
off why do people hate me I need to know
because I can't just keep going about my
day knowing that thousands and thousands
of people hate what I'm doing not
insecure you are I really don't care
that much about any of this it's just I
don't have anything else to do today so
it doesn't matter the world hates me I
don't I don't read comments and like cry
ever like I know I'm great I'm so stupid
so here's my plan I'm going to FaceTime
people who unfollowed me I'm gonna ask
them what I did wrong I'm gonna ask for
their forgiveness try to get them to
follow me back I'm gonna take their
advice and I'm gonna create the greatest
Instagram of all time so I think one of
the most important people who unfollowed
me is my mom I really care about her
opinion and I want to figure out why so
I'm gonna FaceTime her real quick it's
really hurtful when your mom unfollowed
you it's even more hurtful when your mom
doesn't pick up on you so the second
most important person who unfollowed me
was James Charles James Charles
unfollowed me like a good week after he
followed me we were still friends when
he unfollowed me we were still hanging
out as and we never discussed it he
never acknowledged he involved me we
were still hanging out we were still
texting each other he just didn't want
to see me on his Instagram it's fine
James
totally it's fine it's totally fine cool
so none of the people I'm actually close
to care enough about me to pick up so
what I'm gonna do is I'm just gonna
figure out strangers who unfollowed me
on my Instagram and FaceTime them how am
I gonna figure out who won followed me
great question I'm gonna hire an FBI
agent I'm gonna pay millions of dollars
I'm gonna stock this person for years
and then one more how am I gonna find
out who won followed me well good
question I've spent the past week trying
to figure that out
I downloaded an app that told me it
would tell me who unfollowed me
unfortunately the app kept twitching
because I have too many followers so it
can calculate it no big deal man I hate
myself I ended up downloading five
different apps none of them worked then
I came up with a brilliant idea because
I'm brilliant I'm gonna look at old
pictures of mine I'm gonna see who liked
them and see if they still follow me if
not I'm facetiming them let's go on
Instagram okay
I'd like 8,000 followers before this
picture and then I released my body
paint video on BuzzFeed and released
this picture it got thirty thousand
likes I think I gained like fifty
thousand dollars after that video so
let's just scroll and click on random
accounts this guy is forty-nine thousand
followers and he follows me wow that
makes me feel good this girl doesn't
follow me anymore I'm sure to call this
I'm nervous my heart's like racing I
know whoo that's stressful okay pick up
pick up pick up pick up the people from
Instagram are from all over the world so
some of these people might be it might
be like 4:00 a.m. that's just me trying
to come up with the excuses as to why
she did not pick up on me thank you very
much okay she doesn't follow me anymore
either
did she blocked me it's a lot of just
sitting around and having people ignore
your calls oh my god fine don't pick up
I don't care this girl doesn't follow me
literally everyone this girl follows me
thank you very much why was he even ever
following me this guy's like 40 can you
guy with a camera I'm a skinny guy with
the camera as well we have so much in
common why would you unfollow me well if
you pick up I'll know
please pick up it's also hurtful to call
people and be ignored like I bet you if
Ryan Reynolds called someone on
Instagram they'd pick up instantly
pick up pick up pick up on Eric please
a slight a quick question for you
why did you unfollow me when I don't
post I actually lose less and then when
I start posting I lose a lot like people
remember that I exist and then they
unfollow me do you think there's a day
or a chance that I will have you as a
follower again uh so I think if I just
FaceTime every person I could gain back
all my followers hey what's up that's
what they all say that's what they all
say
what did I do to lose lose our
friendship lose our connection Eric de
baak Wow she forgot me so quickly
Eric taboc is the last name of ta ba ch
[Music]
unless Instagram is hates me and their
achievements to unfollow me
well Kate's different that's gonna fire
Nathan
[Music]
yeah Keitel was not but you you
unfollowed me on Instagram yeah doesn't
polite yes when you see em Romania
unfollowed people Mamiya and followed
the catchy bass when you store see
Wagner my god you're proud that he
cocked into the sewer
yeah no drugs night shift she said it's
a good strategy that I'm calling people
because now there's an incentive for her
to follow me back actually every single
person I've called so far has followed
me back so this is uh this is great
I'm building a connection with the
people who don't like me and now they
like me so that really boosts my
confidence because that means in person
I'm likeable
I'm just unlikable on Instagram but I'm
I'm I'm a likable human being I'm not
bad am i I'm so annoying in this video
oh come on this one girl just roll I
followed you but I went to check this
and I saw that I didn't follow maybe
have been automatic or because of the
new update okay everyone is saying they
don't remember on following me is this a
new conspiracy theory Shane Dawson's
about to jump on this because if this is
real if they're not just being nice to
me Instagram is stealing my followers I
could be at a million right now do you
think this is real no dude I'm telling
you I'm about to start an Instagram
conspiracy theory you know one day I
woke up with ten thousand less followers
and then the next day they were all back
it was an Instagram glitch I'm like if
you can erase followers like that then
maybe that's what's happening look at
all these souls man like in my phone
like there's actual there's thousands of
souls inside this cell phone everyone
messages me is this for a video or an
accident i I'm not but dialing you okay
like like you know how hard it is for me
to butt dial someone on my Instagram
this girl roll
I thought your account was hacked or
something what why would a hacker get on
my account and FaceTime you how are you
you're from Portugal
why did you unfollow me oh you never
followed me in the first place you just
looked at my pictures and then never
even followed me thank you thank you I
appreciate it I'll see you around man
dude I just met a guy from Brazil that's
so cool I don't know it's kind of makes
me feel like all of this doesn't matter
like I'm overthinking it like when
people don't follow you or if people
write something mean probably like I
don't even think it means anything to
them it's just so like it's just the
world of social media is so impulsive
and quick and it's not actually thought
through so none of this stuff means
anything I feel like this is what I
cherish like getting to talk to somebody
face-to-face this is so much fun I don't
even care about the Instagram part
really anymore I just want to talk to
people how are you good good thank you
for picking up the phone um
you live in Germany that's amazing how
do you speak English so well you learned
English in South Africa in one year why
did you unfollow me all these people are
awesome man I couldn't tell if that guy
was lying or not but he was so nice he's
a film student in Germany
his English is insane for somebody who
just went to South Africa for a year so
I'm filming a video where I FaceTime
people who unfollowed me why why did you
unfollow me do you remember the day you
unfollowed me May 14
myself to sleep that night no I'm
kidding I did not
I know david dobrik did it so I need to
make some more like really bold funny
videos thank you so much it was a
pleasure to meet you I'll see you around
I can't believe I feel good after
talking to people who unfollowed me this
was a blast to film I hope you guys
enjoyed it genuinely it was such a
pleasure to just talk to strangers and
connect with people and just forget
about the actual thing that I'm making
the video about forget about like the
likes and the Instagram and the follows
and just have human connection and even
people who unfollowed me I didn't hate
me or had nothing against me and I
actually had a great time talking to
them so none of this stuff really
matters am i a hypocrite and do I care
about it yes but I acknowledge that this
is all [ __ ]
[Music]